my brothers and sisters there is a authentic Hadith in
wherein
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam is
marveling from different angles at the amazing Trust
the prophets all had in
Allah azzawajal
so he says in this Hadith
Ibrahim
we
would doubt God before Ibrahim and
of course he would never doubt God which means Ibrahim alaihissalam always trusted God never doubted
him in other words don't misread that Ayah about oh Allah show me how you give
life to the dead he tells them take a bird and chop it up put it
on separate mountains he wanted to increase his trust but he had great trust he
wanted another level that people don't have it's beyond human reach for the most part
and so he's saying he never doubted he always had Supreme trust if
he would have doubted we would have doubted first
then in that same Hadith he goes on to say
set
aside for loot Prophet lot
for he used to certainly seek
strength in
the strongest corner
with the strongest support pillar which is Allah azzawajal meaning don't misread that story of prophet
in the Quran and he said I
wish I had a bigger family
in other words yes he wished he had in
front of his eyes people that could help him from his guests being abducted by those
criminals that wanted to practice indecency with them right against their will he's saying he said
that but his heart never saw but Allah
he used to always keep his trust in Allah firm
he didn't lose hope in Allah and wish his families could sort of compensate no
then the third statement he said in the same Hadith he says
and
me if
I would have remained in prison for as long as Joseph remained in prison I
would have responded to the caller you know when when Joseph was framed and thrown in
prison and then they said to him the king wants to meet you you're really good
at this dream interpretation thing he
said no
he had such trust in Allah that Allah would not just give him his freedom but
he would Restore for him his reputation with the people clear my name first
and so all these three are trust and these are so important because we all need
it whether it's like Ibrahim alaihissalam trusting God and not giving in to The Whispers that
could be doubts later on not with Ibrahim
or
whether it's like
your
security is under threat but you never waver your eyes see Allah and you trust him
throughout whatever security threat services in your life your safety
or whether you're like Yusuf your your reputation your respectability people's opinion of you is threatened
you put your trust in Allah and we all need to grow that trust because these
things are unavoidable the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam told us that there is no uncertainty about
it adversity challenges in life are certain that
part you can be certain about it's
uncertainty in terms of is it going to be in my job or is it going
to be in terms of my children or is it going to be in terms of
like a marital challenge or is it going to be an income challenge we don't know
but you need to know that it will be there and hence we all are in
deep need of growing and regrowing our trust in Allah you see the believer is different
he
does not think that life will get easier
but he believes that through trusting Allah he can get stronger through true and proper tawakul
Reliance on him Supreme trust in God you
can arm her up for whatever life throws at you whatever tomorrow brings per se
for life's blows you can handle them because you know that Allah said
whoever
puts their true trust in Allah truly trusts him Allah will be enough you
know that you can be that person that when the world around you has become so
fragile that they have a meltdown from being pricked by a thorn you
can have an avalanche of hardships in your life and you could just take it in
stride
the great scholar though
he says you need to keep something in mind to grow your tawaku you
will never have an
airtight system you know like a
true tawakul that doesn't fail you true trust and God doesn't fail you without four components
and I want you to remember them today he
says the first of them is to have deep knowledge of Allah
his names his attributes his Perfection or
else how else are you going to trust him you
know I would trust the child you
know with
my pen
I would need an adult to trust them with my car
how do I trust someone with my existence
unless I know them deeply their credibility is clear to me
that's why Allah azzawajal says
you
got to remember that only belonging to Allah is the Unseen don't
have misplaced confidence in
yourself even or
in others excessive confidence nobody knows the Unseen nobody
can tell you what's going to happen five seconds from now so don't trust anybody the
way you trust him belonging to Allah is the Unseen in the skies and the Earth
and
all matters go back to him he's
the ultimate decider who
since
that's the case then devote your life to him and put your trust in him
notice
how because he's the knower of the Unseen because he is the one that says to
a thing be and it is then we devote and we trust what's
you know speaking of B and it is this is of what feeds your your knowledge
of God Hadith
about him we have so much the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said there used to be
a man among the people before you who on his deathbed he gathers his children and
says listen what kind of father was I to you they said you
were the best dad ever he said I need to admit something to you I've never
done any good in my life
for either enemy so once I die you
need to take my body and you need to burn it
and when it is a cold I want you to shatter it cremate me turn me
into ashes and
then once I'm ashes you wait until
it is a windy day and
then Take Me Out To The Shore and throw some of me to the wind and
some of me in the ocean because
if
Allah is able look he even doubted Allah's ability but
he will still get forgiven
if Allah is able to grab a hold of me he will punish me in a
way that he's never punished anyone
he knows he deserves it
and he made each of his children promise or else he would disown them that they
would do this and they didn't
and after they did this whole long thing right
obviously the Hadith is fast forwarding for us the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam says to us
meaning about the day of judgment and then Allah says be Kun
all
of a sudden he's a man standing again just
like that and then Allah says to him o my servant
what
drove you to do all this oh
long story why
he said
I
was afraid of you Allah
it
wasn't long before
Allah enveloped him in his Mercy
other reports of this Hadith indicate that this is actually the
the first chapter of
that story we know from the Hereafter and the other Hadith about the last man to
exit the Hellfire the
last man to enter Paradise
but look be and it is
so that is someone that I can trust I
can relegate I can submit to regarding the unknowns of life
but I need to say it is not just knowledge about him in the theoretical the
other way you cultivate this first pillar deep knowledge of Allah is by devoting yourself to
him or else all the facts in the world won't matter
a
part of not
you know deactivating not rendering pointless for you that
knowledge of Allah is you closing the gap between your knowledge and your actions it's not
fully possible but exerting yourself the
more you devote yourself to him the More Alive these realities that you read about in
the Quran and sunnar so that's the first pillar deep knowledge of Allah through Revelation and
through devotion the
second pillar
of proper Reliance in Allah is to have solid conviction in Destiny
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said to us
if
any one of you were to spend Mount have you ever seen mount
no one has ever done this if you were to spend mounted in Gold it
would not be accepted of you until
you believe in qadar until you believe in destiny
to the degree that you are sure that what hit you wasn't going to miss you
and what missed you was not going to hit you
and
if you are to die believing anything else Allah will admit you to the fire
think about that Allah
is obligating you even with this heavy language to
armor yourself up with the reality that it's all in Allah's hands
I'm making it a must on you to not believe a lie you
must believe that everything is in his hands
believe
in destiny be sure about it
this is the foundation of our faith and you need to also know that shaytan targets
this Foundation this is sort of what he strikes at
the Quran tells you this that
is
shaytan
threatens you with poverty you're going to go broke and
so then he instructs you with indecency because you're afraid of going broke then he's going
to tell you now cut Corners now be unethical or
the other Ayah says that he said to Adam
shall
I direct you to a tree of what of everlasting life the tree of Eternity and
a kingdom that never perishes so he's constantly telling you you need this you're going to
be in trouble you're going to die soon you're going to go broke soon and so
shaitaan he targets these things on purpose
and so Allah's Revelation comes targeting these things to
restore your conviction that your life is in his hands Don't Panic that your Provisions are
in his hands no one can be able to take them away from you
you
need to know that if you would have stayed home those
who were destined to die at that battle would have went out to meet their death
anyway they would have went out to use the bathroom went out for a trade or
a business it
was destined to die here so don't say oh man I don't want to do the
right thing or else my life will be shortened or my finances will be restricted don't
ever accept that be
sure of what Allah is telling you or the other Ayan Hadid on this point when
Allah says no Calamity befalls you on Earth or in the heavens except
that it's recorded in a book before it happens
why
is Allah telling you this he says so you don't grieve too much on what you
because of what you missed out on
and
you don't get too delusional about the good things that come your way it's all written
it's all a test comes in different shapes sizes colors and flavors but it's all just
predestined all predetermined this is ABC's Islam
you know that is why
that
famous Imam I
often recall when the the ruler of his time said to him your life is in
my hands fear me shut your mouth he said to him
if
I actually believe that at my destiny and my life was in your hands it wouldn't
have worshiped anybody but you right
and so when you fold it
is a sign that your knowledge of God is not deep enough our
belief in Destiny has wavered
when you cut corners and try to get married the haramue when
you cut Corners just try to get a raise or a promotion or more income the
haramue
that means you believe you can circumvent the system right the
trust of Allah
needs to be grown regrown at that point so we said deep knowledge of Allah and
we said firm conviction in his Destiny
and
that is reflected by us beautifying our requests as
the Hadith says the third and fourth are very simple
the third of them is that you seek the means that are available to you
meaning everything is destined everything is Allah's will but he gave you enough of agency enough
of a will a choice enough of it at least to
be held responsible for your actions and you see this the prophet when
he went to war he wore armor didn't he when he was fasting and it became
too hot he spilled cold water on his head didn't he
when he got sick he sought out doctors and Medicine didn't he
one
time they told him that a bunch of men were sitting in the Masjid saying we
put our full trust in God
he said these people have never opened the Quran in their life
I'm paraphrasing
he says they have never smelled knowledge forget touch it he said they've never smelled knowledge
he
said didn't they hear Allah
saying to Maryam
our
mother Mary the mother of Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
Shake
towards you the trunk of the palm tree ripe
edible dates will fall on you you know men can't bring dates from a palm tree
like this you gotta go up climb and get it so how can a woman right
after the pain of Labor do it why did Allah tell her that to
show us that you still got to do your part you still gotta try you still
have to reach
that's why the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he said
if you were to trust Allah the way he deserves to be trusted trust Allah fully
and properly he would provide for you the way he provides for the birds
the birds are trying but they're not experts they're sort of trying randomly but they come
home every day with a full stomach for the most part likewise you
want to try but
don't be overconfident in your effort in your energy in your expertise in
your attempt
seek the means though
deep knowledge of Allah solid conviction unwavering Faith about Destiny seeking the available means number fourth
as we just said the fourth one is not relying on those means those means are
effective by Allah's permission you know when they ask the prophet saws should we use medicine
one
time he said
medicine is from what Allah distance meaning if he destineds for you to find it available
you'll find it available and
if he destins for you to hit the spot for you it
will work right you still gotta go for it but know that it's from Allah when
you go for it I was once told about a man and I may have shared
this with you before that used to throw his pill on the ground before taking it
he wasn't crazy he was just trying to remind himself that the doctors are lying the
doctors are short-sighted the
doctors that don't believe in Allah are telling him your life depends on this he's saying
it can't even help itself right I throw it on the ground it's powerless so if
it's gonna help me it's going to help me by Allah's permission
the same way a knife Cuts you're supposed to use knives to cut something right
but he can stop it from cutting the way he stopped it with Ibrahim a
fire burns it can burn it has the quality of burning but it can cause it
to not burn the same way he did with Ibrahim
and
so that is that heart never wavering true
Reliance on Allah means Reliance of the heart while still engaging the reality and I'll share
with you two things in this next in this last minute that
those four components means that you have proper tawakul once
proper telekul is accomplished it doesn't mean you're going to get the outcome you want all
the time sometimes Allah will withhold it from you for a better outcome
right or wrong that's important to remember
secondly says
don't you dare get cheated for your tawakul he
said what does it mean some people do tell wrong we've already discussed that some people
do it right but they sell themselves short like I'm gonna trust Allah correctly for
a job and a wife and a child and some respect and he goes use tawakul
in your Deen Above All Else Allah
can get you past that deadlock can get you to grow Beyond everyone in your generation
can get you to be a reason for the direction of the ummah to accelerate in
positive ways at positive
rates as well you
sawakul for your Deen and Allah will take care of your worldly stay and your religious
commitment may we be people who supremely trust in Allah properly and for the most important
objectives of Our Lives May Allah make us of those who trust before and after the
outcome may we be of those confident in him stepping into tomorrow and the Unseen and
may we be of those who assume the best of him if he decides other than
what we wish for and what we dream about Allah I mean
thank you